[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right.
Hi, I'm Bruce.
I'm an engineer on the Google
Play Game Services team.
And today, I'd like to
share a little bit more
on some new features
that we've built
to help you to automate
your game publishing
processes to the Google
Play with our new APIs.
So first, a little bit
more about our team.
So what's Google
Play Game Services?
It's a bunch of cloud
services such as achievements,
[INAUDIBLE], online multiplayer,
cloud save, and quests.
A shameless plug, I
recommend checking it out
if you have not.
So let's say you're
building a game
and you wanted to push your
game to alpha every day
to your alpha testers.
So maybe you wanted to localize
your game to many languages.
Or maybe your designer
just went crazy,
and he has tons of
achievements he wants to add.
So previously, you'd probably
go to the Google Play Developer
Console and pretty much add
this metadata one by one.
And we've heard your piece.
A lot of developers had a lot
of tedious times doing that.
So we've added two
APIs to help you out.
The first is the Google Play
Game Services publishing API.
And the second is the Google
Play Developer Publishing API
Edits.
And these two can
help you manage
your game services and your
Play Store data, respectively.
So to begin using these APIs,
the first thing you need to do
is to go to the Developer
Console, and click on Settings,
and then go to API Access.
From there, you can follow
the steps to setup the API.
Once you do that, you
should be able to get access
to all these APIs.
For example, this is an
achievements API that we have.
You can get, update, delete,
insert, and list them.
And we also have an
API to upload images
for those achievements.
So let's say you have an
achievement already setup
and you wanted to get an API
so you get the achievement.
Here is an example.
You make an HTTP request
with achievement ID,
and you can get the
JSON response for it.
And pretty much the
same thing for updating.
It's the same URL.
It's just that
it's a put request.
And you can just change
the JSON data and update.
So one tip is that you
should always get [? it ?]
before you update,
because that's how we
deal with concurrent updates.
So here's an example for the
Google Play developer APIs.
You have to create what we
call edit, which is basically
a change list.
And you can commit the edit.
So going back to
the example earlier,
let's say you want to
push your alpha every day.
All you need to do is create
an edit, upload your APK,
set your APK to the
alpha track, and then
finally commit that edit.
And you can do many other
steps in between as well.
So here's a list of other
things that you can do.
You can change your screenshots.
You can change your Play Store
details, manage your testers,
add more localization,
or do staged rollouts.
So by now, you might
be wondering what
if other developers
can access your data.
So no worries about that.
We take permissions
very seriously.
You can manage it in the
Developer Console as well.
And only the owners of your
games can access the data.
So we have also two main ways
to authenticate from the client.
So the first is an OAuth
Client with this OAuth code.
One common mistake is to
lift this [? code ?] up.
So do include that.
And the second is to
use a service account.
So a service account is
basically another account
that you can grant
your rights to.
And this is very useful because
you can set up a built server
and then use that service
account to run your publishing
processes.
Not to forget, Google Play
Games is also cross-platform.
So when you update
your achievement data,
it goes out to all
your platforms,
and you don't have to
worry about it anymore.
So with that, you should be
able to automate your game
publishing processes.
And hopefully, that will
save you a lot of time,
a lot of money, and you
can finally use that time
to maybe eat some cake.
[LAUGHTER]
If you still have problems,
check out our GitHub samples.
We have Python and JavaScript.
And we also have Java samples
for the Google Play Developer
API Edits.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC  PLAYING]